FELICE FRANKEL: Hey, everyone.
This is our first video update.
We are now starting
week one of the course.
I think that what we'll
probably say now more than
anything else is a
quick conversation
about the equipment.
Many of you are concerned that
I'm being a little too picky
in what I'm requiring of you.
Now, first of all, I am not
requiring anything of you.
What I'm doing is showing you
what I do and my technique.
My hope is that you'll like
what I make-- the images that I
make-- and follow my lead.
And for the most
part the exercises
that we've developed
really are intended
to be used with a 105
macro lens on a camera that
can take lenses.
It is not going to
work for you if you
are going to just
use a snap and shoot,
or whatever you
call it these days.
You really want to meet the
standards, if I could say that,
that we are suggesting
you pay attention to.
It is true that you
can, on occasion, use
extension tubes instead
of-- for example,
let's say you don't have as much
of a macro lens as you'd like.
And so you can use
tube extensions as long
as they don't have any glass.
But you'll be losing
f-stops in the process,
and you'll find out more
about aperture and f-stops
in the oncoming weeks.
So those of you
who are technically
savvy, I hope that you'll find
what our exercises have become
developed into.
And the ideas in the course will
be appropriate for your needs
as well.
But just getting back
to the equipment,
for example, when we get up
to using a camera and a lens,
which is in a week
two, you're going
to see that I'm going to
suggest using software.
And you'll probably say,
why is she doing that?
Well I'd like to
hope that I'm going
to be making a case for that.
So in the end, please
consider following
what we're suggesting.
It works for me.
And my hope is that
what works for me
is going to work for you.
But this coming
week, we're going
to have more fun in the
sense that you're not aware
that hard, because you're going
to be using a flatbed scanner
and you're going
to be a bit shocked
at some of the wonderful
images you can get from that.
So in any event, we hope
we're going to create
something wonderful for you.
Have fun this week.